i remember the first time we had a
conversation you were talking to
somebody about being a kid and playing
gay chicken oh yeah
yo when i was young we used to play this
game called
gay chicken they called it uh i didn't
name the game but i was you know i the
game existed and then i then i existed
um
was it your uncle was it a neighbor well
the game was you you and a buddy you'd
grab each other's wiener right penis
they called it in those days some of you
guys call it penis but uh
yeah you grab it and the first person to
get an erection lost the game right
so it's like arm wrestling for a second
it's the stupidest [ __ ] game no it's
not no
did you win did you ever win or did you
lose did you lose a lot or did you win a
lot oh i did real well one season uh
what is the gay chicken season what does
that go from
it's more of a win it's i would say it's
an autumn game
i would say it's kind of well that's so
i think i can see it now the all the
leaves changing colors
and just the two of you do you play with
neighbors or the teams no you just got
them we only had about seven guys that
played in our little bracket or whatever
but they have you know what's weird you
know what's interesting you have seven
guys in your bracket yet it's a two-man
game yeah and so there's an odd number
oh yeah does it have to be two-man can't
you like do it in a circle oh come on
lady no
come on man that's y'all are messed up
y'all are stuck that's called what's
that called uh uh culkin
yeah that's i think yeah yeah no that's
uh boo cocking uh boo cocky i'm not
doing no circle jerky that's gay
caroline is the one okay that's it
caroline no circle turkey and the other
thing that that i remember you
[Music]
you